anyway I'm Emily I'm Nadia today we're
gonna be decorating some cakes hi I'm
Nadia
hi I'm Emily that's Nadia we're loaded I
have little to no experience decorating
any kind of pastries or baked goods not
very good at it
a couple of years ago I made a birthday
cake for my friend from a box 1 to 10
how do you feel it great I feel like I
can talk about zodiacs all day number
baby me one third time I feel a little
it took about 8 and a half but we're I
mean tens obviously I would read cues at
10 I drink you the test we have a six
dollar bunt in front of us I'm excited
to ruin it I need some water
I'm on ready we were born to do this
who have you seen a more beautiful sight
without further ado ladies and gents and
everyone in between
can we start when I was a kid I would
get home from school and take the post
berry frosting like to slather it all
over the saltine crackers psycho so I've
got a whole yes every time yes I will
this we gotta get a crumb layer going
this is a crummy cake so I'm just going
for it here I go oh you're just starting
to print off a bit your mail and you
know oh my god on the table what it got
it filled I'm literally getting
flashbacks gonna take a butter knife
well you were you
icing salty that's the grossest thing
ever anymore probably because of that
it's okay sit you know a little pint of
haagen-dazs every day after school are
you gonna start when he are you eating
your listen it's part of the plan
minimalism just get rid of the cake and
then you don't have to decorate it this
is a competition right this is
petition I guess it is now a brilliant
moment or two thank you we are going to
do what I like to call improvise oh
you're standing yeah I'm getting real
into this right now
Wow I think this is just I should
probably be a baker after this guy I'm
so good at this picture oh yeah oh hell
yes oh my god that's beautiful I have a
question
what's your rising alright get ready to
lose I take it back about the
competition
you can't you said it I'm not gonna lie
okay here we go wait that looks really
good thank you
I'm swirling it I saw this on Instagram
I'm giving up text look at that oh yeah
all right so I nailed this if I ever get
married I think I'd do pies do you think
can I come to your wedding oh my god
you're in it oh my god really hard Emily
I had a fine time
you gotta get you together you know this
might be a metaphor for oh all right I'm
starting to design mine and I'm not
gonna show you yet oh my god wait you
can't you'll see gravity is really not
helping how do they one of the
professionals use like a spoon Hayling
over here so what I'm doing is just
slowly glaze like doing a like light a
light gate come on I'm doing a light
glaze I don't want it to be too frosting
I just want it to be oh my god I've got
frosting all over my body why don't we
get aprons what's your goal I'm just
kind of winging it at this playing in
all of us fellas you know what yes yeah
oh look at how good that looks
[Music]
yeah turning around it's turning right
around so my cake right now says I am
drunk there you go so this is the party
for the drunk part you need more icing
you're slurping it all up I'm trying to
be conservative I would love to take an
art Theory class with you part of the
design is that there's bite taken out of
it I want to pipe some stuff yeah am I
gonna ruin it I don't think so
why don't you test it on mine do you
mean it yes yo see now that looks good
on mine oh my god we'll just do this
serious keep going
are you kidding me are you kidding me
where's my master class I think my cakes
done I think it's a masterpiece I would
probably sell this on Etsy for like 500
bucks I don't want to be done I'm having
a great time are you done this is just
different things this looks like a
unicorn threw up we're done ours is
great I really do like mine a lot I'm
not even gonna lie I feel like we should
Fox it back up and sell it back to the
grocery store one thing I really learned
is less is more
this is the thing it's it's hard to rein
yourself in I would like to point out at
how much more reserved I felt as a
drunkard I wanted to go with the you
know chill look and boy does it look at
you it these look like sober cakes
these look like drunky today yeah oh
good
[Music]